vous aurez qu'est ce que vous faites et
vous m'écoutez c'est un ordre
l'info était désolé on savait pas qu'ils
auraient tous ces civils
maintenant il serait tout à fait normal
que quelqu'un puisse avoir des doutes
sur la moralité de ce qu'il vous
demandons de faire c'est une question
monsieur non non rien concentrez votre
esprit sur ce je vous dis est ce que
vous savez ce qu'on ait des avaleurs de
pêcher les purificateurs on prend en
charge l'excrément morale qu'on peut
trouver dans cette équation et ont
enfoui au plus profond de nous-mêmes que
le reste notre cause demeure pur voilà
notre boulot on est moralement
indéfendable et assurément nécessaire
comprenez